BERNIE BRENNER: I think
the connection here
is obviously about relationship.
You're building rapport.
And relationship is
so important when
it comes to business
development.
And also I say what I
try and communicate often
is the difference between
sales and business development.
And in doing it
for my whole career
as well as hiring
people, I think
it's very sort of appropriate
from your standpoint.
Because I've looked
at people's resumes,
and they have this
incredible resume,
and they stink at what they're
doing in terms of hiring.
So it's not just about that,
and I've learned over the years
that there are certain
key components,
at least in these roles as
it relates to BD-- Business
Development-- which is
a combination of hunting
and there are people
that what we'd
refer to as account managers.
But I've renamed them
partner development managers
because I really like the
word development to be
in there because
they're developing
relationship and developing
a partnership versus managing
an account.
And that's very
much the sales side.
So I understanding
these nuances will also
help in terms of the recruiting
aspect and what to look for.
At least I found it
to be quite effective.
So I'm happy to answer
questions about where
I've made the mistakes over
the years of hiring people
and like, oh my god,
this is a disaster,
and so having to let them go.
And they think
that they're great,
and it's just not the case.
AUDIENCE: I do traditional BD.
BERNIE BRENNER: Say it again.
AUDIENCE: I do traditional BD,
we've got a whole team here.
BERNIE BRENNER: OK, great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
with all your tips.
BERNIE BRENNER: All
right, thank you.
All right, so--
AUDIENCE: And a couple
of us are in deploying
a product [INAUDIBLE].
BERNIE BRENNER: OK,
good, all right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BERNIE BRENNER: Right,
right, all right,
so there'll be--
certainly anything related
to relationship management
is very important.
As I say-- and I have a
podcast, and I'm constantly
talking about this
on the podcast,
so you should all subscribe.
It's called "Extreme
Biz Dev"-- is
that when it comes
to strategic deals,
revenue is prioritized last.
Now, everyone in the ops
world that I work with
is like, what are
you talking about?
Where's the revenue?
Where's our [INAUDIBLE]?
It's relationship first.
And this is all when two
companies come together,
relationship first,
strategic impact second.
This is how you're
prioritizing what you do
and how you interact.
And revenue is
third, and I view it
as revenue is last, because if
you prioritize the other two,
the revenue is going to come.
The opportunity between the two
will be achieved or realized.
So when we talk about
"The Sumo Advantage,"
I'll explain why I
use the term sumo.
And again, this is all
about a mindset shift.
But if you were to ask companies
how you grow your revenue,
most would say,
let's increase sales.
Either add more people,
increase the quotas,
whatever you can
do, lower the price.
But increase sales, and that's
how you increase revenue.
And I'm saying that's not the
only way to think about it.
Obviously that's a critical
way to think about it.
It's important, but
is it sustainable?
And when I say is
it sustainable,
it's really, well,
if you grow sales,
so there's always going
to be some attrition.
So if your goal is
to grow gross sales,
you're going to lose some, so
you've got to make up for that,
and then you've got
to gain even more.
So growing is
harder, because you
have to make up for
what you've lost also.
There's always some attrition
in the sales transaction.
And then what's
the X-factor to it?
So think about that.
You sell, so one-to-one money.
And that's all it is.
And I'm saying from a business
development standpoint,
there's an impact on it.
There's an exponential impact.
And then also of course
does the sales impact
the market, meaning,
if get a deal,
does it really
influence the market,
changed the landscape
of the market,
to ultimately get it where
the market converges on us
and we become a whole product?
And usually this is I'm
talking from the perspective
of a smaller company
partnering with a sumo.
In this case, Google would
be the sumo, of course.
And I use actually Google as
an example not only in the book
but in this presentation here
just normally, not just for you
all.
Because it's a great
example, I think,
of where some entrepreneurs
sometimes go wrong.
So let's get to what is sales?
And so for this discussion,
I like to really boil it down
to something very, very simple.
And I'm not saying
that sales is simple.
I'm saying when you're
thinking about what
is the difference
between sales and BD,
I use paper cups as an example.
I'm selling paper cups.
And so I'm selling cups.
I'm selling more cups.
It's a numbers game.
I have to get more
cups out there, right?
I mean, if you're a
manufacturer of cups,
you've got to get
those cups out there,
the more cups, the better.
That is truly sales.
Your pipeline, your commission
structure, everything
is based on this metric
here, versus business
development, which is vision.
You're pitching this
opportunity that
could happen if these two
companies come together.
But it's very different
from saying, hey,
I have some paper cups.
Do you want them?
So we're going to talk about the
distinctions between these two.
So what does it mean if
you're pinching vision?
Well, there are four
key distinctions
that I've identified that are
the difference between sales
and BD.
And so it's important
to understand.
Because once my view, once
it's identified and defined,
what is business development?
And what is sales?
Because a lot of times,
you'll see these things.
What is BD?
Does it live in sales?
Does it live in marketing?
And sometimes it has
to because the company
doesn't have the resources yet.
But if you really want it
to flourish, in my view,
it's defining it and
treating it differently.
Because if you treat
it differently,
then you'll get
the right results.
So what's the difference?
Distinction number one
is BD is very strategic.
There's nothing terribly
strategic about sales.
There could be
some aspects to it.
You got a distributor.
You got something.
But primarily,
sales, paper cups--
I'm selling cups-- there's
nothing strategic about that.
This is very strategic
because it's about vision.
It's about two companies
partnering together.
So that's distinction
number one.
Number two, there's
no direct revenue.
So when you think about business
development, two companies
cutting a deal
together as partners,
the contract is
created, and all that
is, is the framework for
how two companies are
going to work together
in the future.
Versus sales, there's
direct revenue.
I am selling you paper cups.
We have a whatever
it is, however
you want to determine
what that contract is.
It's just going to be an
invoice, insertion order
on something.
However you're using it to
memorialize the relationship
or formalize it, it's purely,
I will deliver paper cups
on this day.
You will deliver money to
me at some day after that.
Very one-one, there's
direct revenue.
There's no direct
revenue in a BD deal.
And even if there
is some-- sometimes
you have to sweeten the deal a
little bit, touch something up,
there's some infrastructure
or a technology development
that you say, OK, I'll put
a little money into that
to the other partner--
it's insignificant relative
to the size of the opportunity.
So you're not, again,
judging the deal
or managing the relationship
based on that transaction.
So if you think about managing
a relationship in the sales
transaction, this gets
to the account manager
versus the partner
development manager side.
In account management-- this is
why I believe account managers,
they could have a
phenomenal resume.
They're not necessarily
great at partner development.
And the reason why is because
they've sort of evolved
their expertise or
their experience
around a transaction
governing the relationship.
So let's just say a customer
says, you know what?
I want more paper cups.
Great, let me give you an order.
The answer is yes, absolutely.
Oh, but we didn't
deliver in time.
Let me figure out
what's going on there.
Everything is around
pleasing the customer
because the transaction exists.
I want my money.
You want your paper
cups, and everything
is governed around that.
Whether it's telephony service,
or advertising, or whatever,
there's clearly a
deliverable on each side,
and I have to find what
a sales transaction is.
So account managers are
very, very good at that.
But that doesn't translate
into relationship management,
not necessarily.
So they may not be
sealed with that.
One of the key things
that I've found
to be very good at
partner development
is to embrace conflict.
And we all understand this
from a personal relationship
standpoint.
If anybody's read any
books on relationships
and gone to any courses
or anything, which I have.
My wife and I go to these
things, and it's fun.
But it's all about
embracing the conflict.
And if you don't
have any conflict,
then you're not growing
the relationship.
And when I say conflict,
I mean healthy conflict.
I'm not talking about beating
the crap out of somebody,
you know.
So you're not doing
that with your partner.
You're embracing
conflict, which means
that if the partner has a
view of something that's
very different from how you
envision the relationship
and you truly believe it's
not good for the relationship,
you have to confront that.
And account managers-- first of
all, generally, a lot of people
are not comfortable
with conflict,
so you have to look for that.
And then, even if they are,
account managers really very
rarely have conflicted
in their relationship--
[PHONE RINGING]
I'm so sorry.
Very rarely have conflict
in their relationship.
It's usually the customer.
The conflict would
be, I'm really
pissed I didn't get
my cups in time,
and now I can't sell
coffee this week.
That's the conflict.
And the account
manager is, holy shit.
I'll get it to you right away.
We're going to do
an expedited order.
We're going to do this.
I'm going to reroute whatever.
Please, please, please,
please the person.
Please the person.
Please the person because they
want that next order, very,
very different as
you're thinking
about who to hire from a
partner relationship standpoint
or partner development
and account management.
Distinction number
three, and we talked
about the difference
between sales and BD
from a vision standpoint.
Everyone's plate is full.
We're all super busy.
No one has a lot of down time.
So whatever you're pitching
from a vision standpoint
is actually not on somebody's
plate, versus sales
where someone is
assigned here to buy
paper cups for that coffee shop.
You can't sell coffee
without the paper cups.
And someone is, it's
their responsibility
to get the paper cups.
If they don't, they're fired.
That doesn't happen here
in the majority of cases.
When we were going
out with TrueCar
and our first big
partner was USAA,
it's not like they were looking
for a car-buying solution
and how to innovate
and change and disrupt
the automotive space.
In fact, how we got the
relationship was they put out
an RFP-- this is again the
difference between sales
and BD-- they put out
an RFP for technology,
for something called an
automotive configurator.
So this is where you go and you
can say I have 2014, Toyota,
and then Camry comes up
or the other options.
It's a typical configuration.
So they wanted that, and
they were willing to pay.
They wanted to know what
the differences were
between your configurator
and another configurator.
And we all know RFPs
are just about sucking
the information
out of the market
and figuring out what
you're going to do next.
So I responded with,
that's not what you want.
And then I paint
in the RFP, painted
the vision of what could be.
And those are tactics I
use to deal with RFPs.
We don't have to
get into that now.
But the point I'm
trying to make is
it was on someone's plate to
acquire-- in the tech side,
anyway-- to acquire this
configuration technology,
and they were willing
to write a check.
So think about
what's going on here.
There's nothing
strategic about that.
Money was going to change
hands on the finishing end.
And it was on somebody's plate.
So I come in, and
I say, no, no, no.
So first of all, that's a
commodity, and it's free.
No one else is responding
with it's free.
Everyone's a couple hundred
thousand or whatever.
It's free, so let's just
take that issue off the table
right away, because that's
not where you want to go.
You want to do something
bigger for your membership.
And I don't know if any of
you are familiar with USAA,
but right after
we signed, it was
ranked the number-one customer
service brand in the country.
It's an incredible
organization supporting
military and their families.
And you could not get
anything better than them
in terms of being a member
or being a partner of theirs.
Because their brand and their
mission is so true north.
But what I was talking about
wasn't on anybody's plate,
and I had to go through like
six different people then.
Because the person who sent
out the RFP and was evaluating
that was definitely
not the right person
for what I'm talking about.
So we had to move around.
But if I had just responded with
whatever the transaction was,
that was on somebody's plate.
They were ready
for configuration.
Fourth-- so those are
three of the four,
and those I view as factual.
Those are the facts
around the circumstances
of a sales versus BD deal.
The fourth is behavioral.
So now [INAUDIBLE]
understanding and then now
some behavior structure change.
And that comes to focusing on
the no, versus sales, which
is focusing on, how
do I get to yes?
ABC-- Always Be Closing,
Let's close that puppy up.
Let's do it now.
That's sales, right?
This is about focusing
on not getting a no.
And I say not getting a
no because that's all you
as a BD person need
to be concerned
with in the early phase.
Because there's no way
you're getting a yes.
Remember, there's
no direct revenue.
That person's plate is full,
and what you're pitching
is not on it.
So it's about focusing
on not getting a no.
And I think this is a
good example of someone
who wants to jump
off a building.
The negotiator comes in,
and what does he say?
He certainly doesn't start
off with, hey, idiot, get
down from the building
right now, right?
Now you're going to get a no,
and the guy's going to jump,
and now he's dead.
And you did a terrible job.
Right?
No, it's building
rapport, relationship.
It all starts with that.
Take as long as is necessary,
because this negotiator has
to focus on not getting a
no, because no means failure.
No means this individual
now lost their life.
There's no way he's getting
a yes out of the gate.
You can't just speed
it up like in sales.
Hey, listen, I'll
shave 10% off if you
close before the end of the
month so I can make my quota.
That doesn't exist
in this world.
So they're having conversation.
They're building rapport.
Oh, you have two kids?
You know what?
I've got two kids too.
Yeah, we had a rough
time with my wife
and I when we went through this.
Whatever is going on in
this individual's mind,
this negotiator's
trying to bond,
and understand, and build
a trust relationship.
And at some point,
there's a change.
There's an inflection point
where then you will understand
on a BD level, OK, now we
can start getting to yes.
That question may
be-- the partner
and I refer to it as
the sumo-- may say,
what would a
relationship look like?
How would we structure this?
Because now you're
starting to get to yes.
Now there's an opportunity.
It takes a while to get there.
The negotiator at some point
will feel this inflection
point, the bond that
happens, and will say-- wow,
I'm already losing people?
AUDIENCE: She had to go.
AUDIENCE: I'll be right back.
BERNIE BRENNER: It's OK.
I'm kidding.
Will say, you know what?
Come on.
Let's go get a cup of coffee.
Let's go talk about this.
And the guy feels that he
has trust with the negotiator
and says, look, I
can make that lead.
Because there's a
lot of risk here,
because it's so easy to say no.
In the case of BD, remember
someone's plate is full.
We talked about how there's
no immediate revenue.
It requires
additional resources.
It's not on their boss's plate.
It's not on their
boss's boss's plate.
So how could you possibly
say yes when this person,
it's not on their radar.
They're not going to get
in trouble for saying no.
And it's not going to affect
their compensation this year,
even if they took
the risk on us.
So it's very easy to say no.
We're all into my
plate's full, so how
do I get things off my plate?
And so that's the behavioral
change that occurs
and the difference
between sales and BD.
You can not use sales tactics--
that let's speed it up.
Let's close it faster.
I've got to hit my
numbers in the quarter--
when it comes to something
like this in the same way
that you can't use
traditional sales compensation
modeling for these
types of people.
Because you can't rush it.
It's going to happen.
It's an evolution that occurs,
and so you can't bonus someone
on a quarterly basis or give
them commission based on this.
It's not the way to look at
it, not the long-term view.
So it really requires
this evangelic pitch.
When you're pitching
a big company
and all those dynamics exist,
it is about this [INAUDIBLE].
That's how we got USAA, and
American Express, and Consumer
Reports, and all
these other companies.
Because we're talking
about what could be,
and this is going to happen.
So I use the term sumo and
advantage for a couple reasons.
I like sumo because sumo
is a warrior contestant.
They understand how to
deal with an opponent.
They understand the
rules of engagement
because they're a warrior.
Advantage means-- everyone
wants an advantage
in the marketplace.
So this is the goal
that I look for
and what I recommend in
terms of entrepreneurs,
they always look for.
They want to cut the
deal with a big guy.
It's very hard to do, but
they want to get a benefit.
They want to get a gain.
So sumo, to me, is a
much better terminology.
And I'll use the
800-pound gorilla
that everyone wants to go
for in sales, or big whale,
however you refer.
So let's talk about
TrueCar for a second.
Let's talk about how
we went to market.
And we're very successful now.
Without this BD
strategy, we would not
be in existence today.
We would have been dead.
Automotive's a very
difficult place to disrupt.
And so think about-- I
don't know if you all
know what we do-- but
you come to our website.
You put in the car
you're looking for,
and we load up all
the transactions
that happened in the
last whatever, 30 days,
60 days depending on
how much volume there
is in the market
based on the car.
But it's local.
You can get it regional.
You can get it national level.
You get to see what
everybody else paid,
which is transparency that, when
we started, no dealer wants.
They never want to give
you information and power
the consumer, because
they're really
about bringing you in, sitting
you across from the desk,
and then figuring
how to work a deal.
Also our dealers-- now
we have 7,000 dealers--
provide up-front pricing.
So before you get in, before
you even give up your anonymity,
you're getting a price of
what this dealer is going
to charge you for that car
based on how you configure--
complete transparency up front.
They can't communicate with you.
This is like, 8
and 1/2 years ago
when we started the
company or 9 years ago now,
this is not how the
world was working.
So now imagine going
into our sales floor.
So this is how BD
helps accelerate sales.
So imagine our
sales force, which
is people on the street
signing up dealerships.
That's where the sales happen.
That's a typical sales
strategy that we use.
They would knock on
the dealer's door.
And there's 500
different companies
knocking on the dealer's
door every week.
Hey, we're launching a new
website called truecar.com,
and we're going to show
all the transactions that
occurred to give complete
transparency out,
calculate what a good price
is, what an over price is.
And we want you to
provide up-front pricing.
And I know you don't do
any of these things today,
and you would actually
hate it for consumers
to have this information.
But this is what
we want you to do.
Do you imagine what a
dealer's going to say?
Get out.
I mean, they will throw
you out, escort you out.
Get out of here.
I want you to die
because you're the devil.
So we wouldn't be in existence.
And then we have a
chicken and egg issue.
Even if they were interested
and we got past the get out.
I want to kill you, the
next question will be,
how many visitors do you have?
We don't have any
visitors because we
need the dealers to
get the visitors.
So we need you first so we
can then attract consumers.
Yeah, call me back when
you have some traffic.
Or the next question would
be, what's your quality?
We don't know what
the quality is yet
because we don't have
any visitors because we
need the dealers.
And then so now we're in limbo.
That's not how we
went to market.
We'd be dead today if we
went to market that way.
There's no way we
could have disrupted
this behavioral change
leveraging just our own brand
and starting out from scratch.
So what do we do?
We had a heavy BD model
where we went out,
and we private labeled.
Capital One, Consumer
Reports, American Express,
Geico, Nationwide, [INAUDIBLE].
We have over 100 brands
that we power for.
And now the
conversation changes.
So now before we had
website, before we
had any customers coming in,
we're walking into dealers,
and we're saying,
hey, do you want
to be part of the USAA
Car Buying Service
and be a USAA certified dealer?
The answer is yes
almost 100% of the time.
If you're in a military
town and you're a dealer,
you want to be that dealer.
You want to make
sure that you are,
and you certainly don't
want to be in a situation
where you're not and
your competitor is.
And remember, the competitor
is the other Toyota store
in the market, not
Toyota versus Nissan.
They actually don't
compete amongst brands.
They compete in their own brand.
So now we're over that issue.
Never did we have a question
how many customers did we have.
Because the answer was,
well, USAA has at the time
8 million members.
So they're like, oh, great.
Not one of them
visited the site yet
because we didn't have a
site, but it didn't matter.
And now we're saying, by
the way, we need that chain.
We want the up-front pricing.
OK, you know what?
For USAA members, I'll do it.
So that's how we created change.
Absolutely there's
no way we would
have gotten it done
without leveraging
the sumo in this space.
And this is an example of
what these sites look like.
This is American Express's site.
This is us on our servers.
But we've adopted
American Express.
It's seamless.
You log in, all that
information gets
transferred so you
don't have to reenter.
The forms pre-pop when
you're ready to submit
your information.
So it's very, very seamless.
There's an integration
strategy there,
integration component to it.
This is Consumer Reports.
Again, this is us.
So that's how we went to
market to leverage that brand.
Then of course we
launched truecar.com
much later on where we had
the base of dealers already.
Now, sumo versus gorilla, we're
all familiar with the term,
let's get the 800-pound
gorilla in the space,
or that is the
800-pound gorilla.
Gosh, if I can land
them for paper.
Someone who's selling
paper cup, gosh,
if I can get Starbucks--
that's the 800-pound gorilla
in the space.
They want it.
Here's the problem
with the gorilla,
in my view, when you're
talking about strategic deals.
They're not big
into thought here.
And there's all
these books the talk
about go getting the whale.
Go close that whale.
Get the big sale.
Get the 800-pound gorilla.
And that's great.
That will bring
you a pile of cash.
There's nothing wrong
with a pile of cash.
We all love cash.
But what you're not
getting out of the gorilla
is the critical thinking.
And that's where a
sumo line works well.
So sumo gives you
exponential power
because you're leveraging
the sumo's assets.
If you're going to
fight in the ring,
remember you're
cutting this deal.
We cut the deal
with USAA so that we
can compete in our market,
not compete in USAA's market.
We were leveraging their assets.
So now when you're
going to market,
you're taking the sumo
who's standing behind you,
and you've got all the
assets of the sumo.
And they're a warrior.
They know how to
compete in the ring.
They understand the
rules of engagement.
And now you're
leveraging the strategy
that they can bring
in, how they execute.
They understand
how to prioritize.
They understand how to improve.
Gorilla doesn't do that.
Gorilla is just sheer power.
So when you're talking
about a sales deal
and the gorilla says,
I want more cups,
you better get them
more cups, or you've
messed up the delivery.
You better fix that.
That's what a gorilla gives
you, good volume, big money,
but also there's a different
level of support there.
Versus the sumo, when
you're competing,
you have this guy on your side.
And so of course then
you get to compete,
and you're leveraging
the sumo's power.
So when we're out in the market,
we're now as big as USAA.
We don't have one
dollar of revenue yet.
visitor to the site.
But we are now in the
market as big as USAA.
That's the unique difference
between BD and sales.
Now, that doesn't mean it
isn't good to say, hey,
we provide paper
cups for Starbucks.
OK, there's credibility there.
You can deliver.
You can deliver on time.
You can mass produce.
There's all the
advantages to that.
But that's not going
to necessarily get
the market to converge.
We're trying to
change the market.
We're trying to change
dealer behavior.
market understanding.
We're trying to get consumers to
come in and adopt this strategy
that we're also embraced the
information, so a lot that
has to go on there.
So in the organization
there's a product layer.
There's a sales and
marketing layer.
And what I'm saying
there is the layer
that needs to be installed to
help with sales and marketing.
And really the BD later
bolts onto products.
So the product people need
to understand that if you're
going to go after the strategy,
that there may be some product
augmentation.
You're not going to build
a whole new product.
But in the case of
our platform, we
had to accommodate the
idea that, wow, we're
going to power USAA.
And people, USAA members,
are going to log in.
And when they come to
our site, over to us,
we're not going to ask
them to log in again.
That would be a disconnected
experience, especially
under the same brand.
So we need to deal with
the security issues,
and we need to deal with
the handshake capabilities
of transferring the data all
understanding what USAA is.
And USAA's so crazy
on the security side.
Just to give you an
understanding, for us
as a small company
starting out, for us
to do the deal with
them, we thought
we were fairly secure already.
And we had to strike
a million-dollar check
just to increase the
infrastructure on the security
side to deal with USAA.
So a million dollars
just on security--
it doesn't generate
revenue-- is tough
when you're talking
about a start-up.
But we did it, because we
understood the opportunity
there.
And that's hard.
The ROI on that is
zero in the first year,
in the first two years.
It's not something you
need to think about.
So here's what happens
when you, I believe,
when you install a BD layer
from a revenue standpoint.
And so your revenue's
going to grow.
Of course your revenue
is going to grow
if you're a thriving business.
But with BD, on the out
years, is grows faster.
There's a big difference
between going the normal path
on your own and
increasing your revenue.
And actually I just
on this week's podcast
that just launched,
I had Greg Brogger,
who's the president of
an NASDAQ Private Market.
And I don't know if
you're familiar with them.
They launched.
It's basically for
private companies
to get some liquidity.
And he had his company
share his post.
And he realized,
wow, you know what?
I can go along, of course.
That's fine.
And he did like $1.8 I think
it was billion, $1.2 billion
in the first 18 months of
his business of transactions,
and that was because of
Facebook and LinkedIn, Twitter
before they went public.
Maybe not LinkedIn, but
certainly Facebook and I
think Twitter.
But it's hard.
He didn't have the credibility.
So he cut a deal with NASDAQ.
I mean, how can you get
any better than that?
And NASDAQ then has the
advantage of going upstream.
But his revenue-- and
he spent over a year.
He cut that deal
a long time ago.
He spent over a year developing,
building, doing these things.
So in the first year, your
revenue is not going to change.
That's the key.
That's the thing to look at.
When you're talking about
investing in a sumo,
in a BD layer in
a partnership, you
can't look at ROI over
a one-year period.
You have to look
at ROI over three,
four year period, the long term.
And in his
perspective, he's going
to achieve much more than
he could have achieved
on his own, leveraging NASDAQ
and all the assets of NASDAQ
in what he's going after.
And it's not like NASDAQ
wants to go after that.
NASDAQ wants the
relationship for upstream.
These companies
eventually will go public.
They'll have a relationship
with NASDAQ, that type of thing.
But he knows that he
would be here on his own.
And he goes with a
sumo, he'll be here.
And it's the same thing with
TrueCar and other examples.
So let me give you, I think the
next is an example-- oh no, OK.
So when you're thinking
about BD versus sales,
it's about thinking
strategically.
And the question is
always, why partner?
Because you think about
you want to go to market,
why do you partner?
Well, do you want to
borrow credibility?
We talked about that.
Solving the chicken and egg
issue, there's differentiation.
When we're going to market,
we're definitely different.
There's no one else
representing USAA
to the dealer community
other than us.
We are completely different
than Edmunds, and Autobytel,
and others that are
selling out there.
No one else has access
to this membership base.
American Express
Black Card, Gold Card,
Platinum Card like we do.
We are different, period.
Risk, you can mitigate
some risk as you
go to market by leveraging
the assets of that sumo.
Better platform for
disruption, certainly
if you're in a space where you
want to disrupt leveraging,
again, the weight
of the sumo to help
you complete in your
organization, in your market
is key.
And then of course
enterprise value.
And again, I talked to a
lot of smaller companies,
and they're raising capital.
And you cut a deal
like this, it's
usually your valuation doubling.
And for them at the early
stages, it's very important.
So that's the sumo
versus the gorilla.
And now let's use an
example of Groupon.
This is where Google plays in.
So Groupon, we're all familiar
with Groupon, I'm sure.
And Groupon went public
in November of 2011 at $25
and over time cratered down
to whatever it went down,
low of $4, $5-- $4, $3.
And then it's climbing back
up in the $10, $11, $12 range.
I don't even know
where it is today,
but clearly a lot less
than what they went public.
Everyone who bought stock
lost money pretty much.
So let's look at Groupon as
an example of, in my view,
having no strategic
thought whatsoever
or installing a BD
layer, I should say.
So Google comes along
and says, hey, I
want to buy you for $6
billion, I think it was.
And you know what Groupon said?
We all know.
No, forget it.
I'm not hooking up with you.
Now, if you're Groupon and
Google is knocking on your door
and saying, hey,
I want to buy you,
and you say no, what
should you assume?
Google is going to come
in and try and kick
your ass afterwards, right?
Because there's no barrier
to entry in this space.
So Google goes, all right.
We all know, and then
Google builds Google Offers.
That was inevitable.
And there's a hundred
different companies
that do these flash
sales now, right?
So this is why
Groupon is in trouble.
This is why Groupon is
struggling to get back.
Because the market's
saturated with this.
Every yoga studio
and sandwich shop
is getting bombarded
by all these people.
And you know what?
If I'm going to pick, Groupon,
OK, they deliver some value.
Oh no, I want to be on Google.
There's an advantage
that Google has,
brand, presence, being
aligned with Google,
there's so many aspects to that.
And Google's just bigger,
and it's hard to compete.
So Groupon did do
a strategic deal.
But this is where I say I don't
think it was the right one.
It's an OK deal, but they
did a deal with Expedia
for partnership for the travel.
But that's not why people
and consumers go to Groupon.
They're not looking to spend
$1,000 on a trip or $500
on a trip.
They're looking to spend $11
for $30 of yoga activity.
So they cut a deal, and it
actually didn't help them.
They said, I don't want
to deal with travel,
so we'll just give it out.
But they weren't
leveraging the sumo
to help compete with Google.
Because Google wasn't
going to focus on travel.
Google's focusing on the
sandwich shops, and the yoga
studios, and the hair
salons, exactly where
Groupon's space is.
And so is everyone
else is doing it.
So as an example
of another company
that had a strategic view
of what to do, LivingSocial,
are you familiar
with LivingSocial?
They came up the
same time as Groupon.
LivingSocial sees Google
getting in the space
and says, holy shit,
what are we going to do?
We need to think about this.
Because no one wants to
compete with Google, right?
So what do they do?
They cut a deal with Amazon
and create Amazon Local.
That's a smart deal.
If you're going to
compete with Google,
I'd say the next company
to think about is Amazon.
That is a deal that says, OK,
I'm prepared for the market.
I see what's coming.
I need some differentiation,
and I need some power.
So when LivingSocial is knocking
on the yoga studio's door,
and Groupon is and the
other hundred companies,
and they said, well, which
one am I going to choose?
Well, LivingSocial is
now as big as Amazon.
The integration is there.
So if you're on Amazon
and you're logged in,
and you buy an Amazon Local
product or service whatever
that is really powered
by LivingSocial,
you don't have to
re-enter your information.
They use the Amazon credit card.
All that stuff exists.
It's really, really simple.
Amazon's got a great
reputation, obviously.
It's growing, group of customers
that's spending a lot of money.
So if you're
thinking about, where
do I want to go, you know what?
I want the clientele
from Amazon.
I don't know what clientele
Groupon is getting,
but I know what clientele
LivingSocial is getting.
And if you're a yoga studio,
you want a certain type
of clientele.
You don't want someone who's
always looking for the discount
because then you'll
never make money.
The idea is bring them
in, introduce them
to what I can do, and then
ultimately they can pay.
And Amazon has a
affluent demographic.
So this is a big
difference here,
and this is how I look at
how to address the market.
And so others will
ask often, well,
how do you identify a sumo?
And so the easiest
way to do it--
there's multiple
ways of doing it--
but the easiest way
is to think about,
if someone else did a
deal, if my competitor did
a deal with another company,
how am I going to get screwed?
So LivingSocial
will tell you, wow,
if Groupon did a
deal with Google,
that's going to screw me.
Now, they didn't do the
deal, but then Google
gets in the space anyway.
So if I have to compete with
Google and Google's going
to go acquire Groupon,
what should I do?
All right, I need to go
cut a deal with Amazon.
So you're thinking
about how you can
get hurt if someone-- so you're
either going to do that deal
or counter and do
a different deal
or figure out how
you're going to respond.
Because you have to assume that
that deal is going to get done.
So SpareFoot's another
example of a company local
here in Austin.
Very similar to TrueCar, I mean
from a modeling standpoint,
not in terms of what they do.
Largest inventory of
storage facilities, and you
think, storage facilities,
how exciting is that?
These guys are
killing it right now.
I think they just raised $50
million, another $50 million.
So they're just
crushing the market.
And what they're doing is
they're going and saying,
there's the Publics, which are
the big storage facilities,
and that's one right there.
And then there's
all these other guys
that needs to
compete with Publics.
It's hard for them to do it.
So SpareFoot is
this marketplace.
You come online.
You get to see what the price
is for that cube, what's
available, and then you
can book it right there.
And so they're helping
me get the smaller
guy able to compete where they
couldn't do it on their own.
So SpareFoot's leveraging that.
But what does SpareFoot need?
They need traffic.
They need good quality traffic.
So what do they do?
Yeah, they're doing their
SEN and of course optimizing
as much as they can with SEO.
But they're looking
for ways to get really
good quality traffic
embedded at the time when
a person needs it.
So what do they do?
They cut at deal with
Penske Truck Rental.
So now we got all these
people calling Penske saying,
hey, I want to book a truck.
Great, now Penske can
offer, do you need storage?
And a certain percentage
of the time they do.
And you know what?
If a person needs storage and
they book it through SpareFoot
through Penske,
Penske's close rate
goes up substantially in
terms of them booking a truck.
Because right now, Penske,
someone's calling up
and saying, what's your
rate versus U-Haul's rate?
And right now, U-Haul
has storage facilities.
They do trucks and storage.
Penske doesn't do
the storage side.
They don't want to get into it.
So Penske is winning
by getting access
to more facilities
than what U-Haul has,
8,000, 7,000, whatever it
is, with up-front pricing
right there on all these
different facilities
so they can find the
best price in the market.
Plus, they're able to, because
of some revenue sharing,
they're able to supplement
even their pricing on Penske.
So now if you call
and you do the bundle,
your actual rate for your
truck could be lower.
So when you're thinking
about competing,
how am I going to
compete with-- or if I'm
making a choice of Penske
or U-Haul, oh, well
the Penske truck's cheaper.
Because I've got to
do the storage anyway.
So there's an advantage to both.
But that's how SpareFoot--
and now that SpareFoot
is bringing this down to their
facilities and saying, listen,
we have Penske volume here.
You can't get that on your own.
You want to sign
up for SpareFoot.
So these are hard deals to
win, but they can be won.
Usually it's from
the perspective
of a small guy getting the
attention of a big guy,
us trying to get the
attention of a Google.
It's hard to do, or Amazon, or
any of these others, you know.
So strategic partnerships,
it requires a change
to embrace this.
One is a mindset shift,
different from sales.
What type of people
you're going to hire,
how you're going
to compensate them.
People, we just talked about
different types of people
embrace sales versus BD.
Process, the process could
change for how you manage them,
how you're going to organize
the company around the resources
necessary to execute on
a deal, and then culture.
There needs to be
a culture shift,
embracing the idea that
a strategic deal is going
to bring value, but it's not
going to bring value now,
not in the next year.
And we're all crunching
for our numbers.
It's hard.
It's not easy to embrace this.
I have more challenges
internally sometimes getting
a deal one because the
COO or CTO is like,
what's the ROI on this?
And my answer is,
there's no ROI on this.
Stop asking the question.
That's not the right question.
What's the opportunity
is the right question.
But they don't want to deal
in that because it's too soft.
So that is the sumo advantage.
Yeah.
And so the term sumo advantage
is an entrepreneur's alignment
with a major market
force, capability,
or accelerator with intent
to grow market share
and crush your competition.
So I always talk
about small companies
should be thinking about how
to gain a sumo advantage when
they're competing in the market.
The Amazon Local
with the LivingSocial
is a great example of that.
So that's it.
Thank you.
I am a partner in
Capital Factory.
And if any of you ever want
to come down, hang out, take
a tour, talk to others,
it's such a great place.
There's much energy there.
Entrepreneurs are
all over the place
and always looking for more
information and just meeting
people.
So it's a great place to be.
Email me if you're interested.
Also, I have a podcast,
"Extreme Biz Dev."
It's fun.
Love it.
So if you know of any
deals that are happening,
email me as well.
You can just email me
bd@berniebrenner.com
or maybe on Twitter
or something.
And I always need more content.
I always love giving exposure
to deals that happen.
So that's it, and I'm
happy to answer questions.
So what's the first one?
Anybody have any?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So, how do you
quantify the success of someone
in BD as opposed to sales
if they are separate?
BERNIE BRENNER: So in
terms of the BD pipeline,
because that's how you're
measuring performance here,
let's identify
the hunters first.
So the typical
sales pipeline, I'm
selling paper cups--
this way more?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, just it's--
BERNIE BRENNER: Oh, sorry, OK.
MALE SPEAKER: You get washed
out on the screen there.
BERNIE BRENNER: Got it.
I'm selling paper cups.
So typical sales forecasting
is, all right, I've
pitched companies that buy
100,000 paper cups a month
or a quarter, and my probability
of closing this month is 10%,
so I'm going to
sell 10,000 cups.
That's how you're
measuring that.
BD is different.
So there's what I've embraced
versus that, because you don't
want them focused on
the revenue, especially
since there isn't any
when they first close.
You want to focus on closing.
So there are stages
of the BD deal.
So there's targets, and
then there's pitches,
and then the next
phase is, let's move
to a non-disclosure agreement.
Then after that, they could fall
out, so they can go inactive.
Or then you move
to a term sheet,
and then to an agreement,
and then you're launching.
So I may say, all right, we're
going after the insurance
vertical TrueCar.
And let's say at the time
we have no insurance guys.
We have pretty much
all of them now.
But what we want to do, we want
to align with three insurance
companies this year, of
the top 10, let's just say.
So I want 7 of
the top 10 pitched
in H1, first half of the year.
I want two of them to
go to an NDA in H1,
and I want one of
them closed in H1.
Let's just say
that's reasonable.
It's practically not
with those big companies,
but that's the way you do it.
And by the end of
the year, we need
to have three launched,
or two launched,
or whatever that
metric is, whatever
you think is important
and reasonable.
If we already have
five on board,
then getting the
next five is actually
easier than the first
[INAUDIBLE] five.
So you're measure
them in stages, and I
want to have three in this
phase, and two in this phase,
and one in this
phase, and whatever.
And if they don't hit it,
then it affects their bonus.
But it's bonus
structure, and they're
measured on this identification
of the number in each segment.
So let's say it's
insurance and then
membership and then
financial institutions.
So we would have different
numbers to hit for each one.
And their bonus is made up
primarily of their performance,
and then a certain
percentage-- let's say 25%--
is based on company performance.
And everyone gets
options at TrueCar.
That's how I do it.
So they have to hit phases,
and if they're not hitting it,
then it's very clear.
So you have to identify
the objectives,
but it's not close this many
this month or this quarter.
AUDIENCE: It must
be tough to assess
the quality of the
relationship, right?
BERNIE BRENNER: Well,
the relationship--
you mean the quality of the
opportunity or the relationship
that they're building?
AUDIENCE: The relationship
they're building.
BERNIE BRENNER: Yeah, but
you're meeting with them.
You're doing one-on-ones.
You're understanding how
they're communicating
and what's going on.
You're seeing enough
activity to understand
whether they're
progressing or not.
Look, it took me four years
to get Consumer Reports
because that deal,
they're a nonprofit.
They think there's
no way we can get
into helping a
consumer buy a car.
We're just about information.
It took a long time
to convince them
from a visionary standpoint
that they're actually
failing their members by
just giving them information.
So you'll get an idea.
I don't find that
to be that hard.
It's more of the
understanding, look,
if you haven't pitched
10, what is your problem?
You're not getting
in the door right.
So that's sort of a talent
assessment right there.
If they just can't
get in the door right,
they don't know how to,
either they're junior
and they need to be brought up
properly and mentored properly.
Or if they're a senior
person and they can't do it,
then you've got
to move them out.
Maybe a different role,
but they're not doing it.
Now on the relationship
side, afterwards, the PDMs,
that's a different story.
So I say to them-- Partner
Development Managers--
I want you to identify
a three-year agenda.
What are all the
things you can do
with that partner over
the next three years?
Put them all down, no time line.
Just put them all down,
all the opportunities.
Now, what do you think you
can get done in the next six
months?
You're not going to get it all
done, but what do you think's
reasonable?
Or the next year, and you
give that to the partner.
You're not giving the
partner three years
of things to think about.
It's just too much,
and they need to focus,
and it's unreasonable, and
there's no [INAUDIBLE].
But if you focus on what we
can do in the next six months,
you'll probably
get half of that.
And then you're seeing
how that's progressing.
And if you didn't get
the meaningful ones,
and you can see as
things are being deployed
and how their
relationship is building.
Because if you're not
getting the meaningful ones,
if you're not getting the
ones that are hard to do,
then the relationship
isn't progressing properly.
That make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
BERNIE BRENNER: So you can
see this has big impact.
Let's blast out an
email to 10,000 members
of the organization.
And let's say the
organization has 10 million.
OK, that's called a test.
If they don't get to half a
million or a million that year,
then something's wrong.
The test didn't work, or
they're blowing you off.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
BERNIE BRENNER: OK, so
that's how I do that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested
in the piece where
you talked about the
evangelical pitch.
And maybe you could speak
to it to TrueCar just
from a brand-agnostic piece.
But what do the big
companies tend to respond to?
It's kind of like it has
to touch their spirit
and inspire them.
BERNIE BRENNER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Maybe innovation
gets thrown around a lot.
If you can talk about ways
to find a pitch and what
speaks to the top guys.
BERNIE BRENNER: Good question.
This gets back to
the not getting a no.
So you think about, firstly, I
start off with the assumption
that in most cases--
not Google's case,
because you guys
are truly unique--
but intraprenurial
efforts rarely
work in a big corporation.
That's why they acquire
so many companies.
Either they don't
want to take the risk.
They don't have the energy.
They're not assigning
the people properly.
You guys are different,
but in most cases,
inside efforts don't work
from a startup standpoint.
So you going in and say
to a big company, hey,
this is my vision, and
this is going to happen.
And you're doing it,
this evangelic pitch,
with such conviction
that this is
going to happen whether
you're on the train or not.
This train's moving.
Are you sitting?
Are you at the train station,
or are you on the train?
And all that is is
making them think, shit,
do I not want to
be on the train?
I mean, really it's
that type of thing.
I don't want to say
no to a train that's
moving when I want to
move in that direction.
So I can't say no yet.
And you're creating
this opportunity,
but it's really about
this conviction.
We are going to make this work.
We've raised whatever
amount of money,
or we have this
many people, and we
are focused on this one
thing-- you're welcome, thanks.
We're focused on this
one thing, and we're
going to get this to work right.
And you know what?
This could be great for you too.
Now, a lot of times,
they don't think
how great it's going to
be because they think,
well, we're big.
How can you really
do this for us?
But it's the idea of that
wow, if I don't do this,
do I want to be the person
that says no to this?
And so it's sort of
that balance of keeping
them intrigued enough
so that you don't
get the no but with
absolute conviction
that this is going to happen.
That's one way.
The other way is to-- a
part of that conviction--
is to do something that I refer
to as triangular attraction.
So I'll give you an example.
In '97, I founded a
company called Promisemark.
And this was in the
internet security privacy
space, identity theft, before
it exploded and became real big.
So I thought that was going
to be a big opportunity.
And it was taking a different
approach to the problem.
It was dealing the viruses,
and firewalls, and all
that other crap that
technology is working with,
but putting a service
component to it,
basically a warranty,
an insurance policy.
Hey, listen, if you
ever get a virus
and it messes up your computer,
we'll fix it for free.
You lose your data, we'll
get it back, no problem.
You're a victim of identity
theft, we'll fix the problem.
We have people here,
and we'll cover you
for $100,000 worth of
damage or whatever.
Back then, we were
the pioneers in this.
So in order to launch this
company, I had no money.
I did not raise any money
yet, or any big money.
I had probably a
little seed money.
I'm sitting in my
basement, and I'm
negotiating with these two
multi-billion dollar companies.
And it's just me.
One of them is the company
called Aon Warranty Group,
which was the largest specialty
underwriter in the world
for warranties and
administration of warranties.
And the other was
Symantec for Norton.
So I'm calling each of
them, and I'm saying, hey,
you need to be part of this.
And then they're saying, yeah,
we need to be part of it.
And of course, none of them have
a reason to be part of this.
They're like, it's
too much risk.
Is this really going to be big?
So what I had to
do was say, listen,
when I was talking to Aon--
the [INAUDIBLE] margin
group-- I'm saying, listen.
Symantec is involved in this.
They're really interested,
which was true.
I am in dialogue with them.
At that point, Aon,
it can't say no.
They're like, holy crap.
Well, the train is moving.
And Symantec may be on it,
another multi-billion dollar
company?
All right, I can't
say no to this yet.
Now, when I'm on the
phone with Symantec,
I'm saying, Aon Warranty
Group, the largest specialty
underwriter in the world who
provides all the warranties
for at the time CompUSA
when it was still around,
Staples, and this
one and that one,
they're interested in
supporting this product
and taking the market too.
At that point, Symantec
couldn't say no.
They weren't saying yes yet,
but there's no way-- again,
I'm communicating this
what's going to happen.
And this train is moving,
and at that point,
I was leveraging
them to validate
what I was doing, which
is they couldn't say
no because if Aon's
in it, it could
be a problem for Symantec.
They want to be involved,
and they'd rather
be involved than
McAfee be involved.
And same thing with Aon.
Symantec's involved,
all right, well,
Bernie can get underwriting
in other places.
We're the largest
specialty underwriter.
We should be involved in this.
And it ultimately worked.
And we went to market, and then
I sold the company to Experian.
So that's how I use the pitch,
the evangelic conviction
that these companies should
at least be talking to me.
Not everyone's going to say yes.
But even when they
don't say yes--
Consumer Reports
never said no to me.
It took four years
to do the deal.
I never got a no.
They got, well, I don't
know if we can do this.
We can't do this.
It doesn't seem right.
That wasn't a flat out,
don't call me again, Bernie.
I never got a no.
It took four years to get a
yes, but I never got a no.
And that's what you want.
Other questions?
All right, well
thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BERNIE BRENNER: Everyone
a free copy of the book,
and I brought some--